Hello, I am Vladimir
Grubišić and
I am an assistant
professor in the
Department of
Biomedical Sciences.
This lecture is
an overview of the
Autonomic Nervous
System or ANS.
This system is
important for
maintaining body
homeostasis.
We will learn about
the anatomy and
physiology of the
ANS and we will go
over gross anatomy
and functions, as
well as some autonomic
dysfunctions.
The objectives of this
session are to learn
the neuroanatomy and
neurotransmitters
of the ANS, know and
understand the actions
of the two opposing
branches of the ANS,
sympathetic and
parasympathetic
nervous systems,
learn about
the enteric
nervous system,
comprehend
autonomic reflexes
and several
autonomic disorders.
Let's begin by
talking about the
organization of
the nervous system.
The nervous system
is categorized
by two major
divisions the central
and peripheral
nervous systems.
The central nervous
system is grossly
divided into six
main parts and the
peripheral nervous
system consists of the
autonomic and the
somatic components.
Today's session
is on the ANS
and its branches,
sympathetic,
parasympathetic and
enteric nervous systems.
Let's briefly talk
about the nomenclature.
Autonomic means
self-governed,
meaning that works
independently from
the higher voluntary
brain centers.
The ANS works
involuntarily below
our conscious
thoughts to maintain
homeostasis of fairly
stable conditions
that are necessary
for survival.
In other words, ANS
is preparing our
body respond to
external stimuli.
To keep this
homeostasis, ANS is
using negative
feedback loops
as shown here in
this schematic.
A solid line indicates
the connected
components are
directly related, so
an increase in one
component leads to
an increase in the
connected component,
while a decrease
will lead to a
decrease in the
connected components.
A dashed line,
like one over
here, indicates
the connected
components are
inversely related.
So an increase
in one component
leads to a decrease
in components
that are connected
and vice versa.
Negative feedback acts to
maintain the
control variable
within a narrow
range of values.
For example when
outside temperature
is high our
body starts to
This heating is
perceived by the sensory
system which sends
signals to the central
control that compares
it to the defined
set point and in
turn sends inhibitory
signals to the centers
that produce heat.
Now, as the body
temperature goes down,
the sensor detects
this temperature change
and sends cooling
signals to the center
which then activates
the heat centers.
Now, the system with
two effectors allows
better or tighter
control of the set
temperature, as shown
in this schematic.
Negative feedback
acts to maintain
the room
temperature within a
narrow range of
values, despite
changes in the
ambient temperature.
for example the
thermostat is set at 70
Fahrenheit and the change
in the room temperature
is picked up by
the thermometer or
sensor if the room
temperature is above the
set point thermostat
activates the AC and
turns off the furnace
on other hand when the
room temperature goes
below the set point,
the thermostat
turns on the
furnace and
shuts off the AC.
Now if you understand
this cartoon
you also understand
the basic
principle of
the ANS control.
The two branches of
the ANS sympathetic
and parasympathetic
act as accelerators or
brakes to keep the
blood pressure at the
defined set point we
will talk about the
baroreceptor reflex
later in this session
so just a brief
overview increased blood
pressure stretches
the arterial walls
and and baroreceptors
within the blood vessel
walls get activated
and signals to the
nucleus tractus
solitarius that in turn
inhibits sympathetic
and activates
parasympathetic efferents
to reduce the cardiac
output and total
peripheral resistance
resulting in the
decreased blood pressure
So, parasympathetic and
sympathetic branches
of the ANS keep this
dynamic balance between
the rest and digest
and fight or flight.
In general,
the sympathetic
system prepares a body
for stressful response
and the parasympathetic
governs recovery
from the stress.
Autonomic control
areas are found
in the brainstem
and hypothalamus.
Feeding control,
water balance and
heat control are in
the hypothalamus.
The urinary bladder
centers are in the
midbrain and the
cardiovascular centers
in the pons and
medulla omblogata.
These centers control
involuntary
autonomic reflexes.
They are also connected
to higher centers
in the cortex, which
allows us to have
conscious control over
these circuits, for
example, voluntary
control over breathing.
Here is a list of
actions of these
two ANS branches
on several organs.
Sympathetic is
preparing our bodies for
action or reaction
to a stressful
event, such as fight
or flight. It increases
blood circulation
and oxygenation,
redirects the
blood flow from the
periphery to the skeletal
muscles, recruits
energy from liver
and adipose tissue,
and shuts down
processes that are less
important during
the stress response,
such as digestive
and urinary systems.
Parasympathetic,
on the other hand,
is mediating
opposing reactions
that lead to recovery.
This dual innervation
provides more
control over these
involuntary responses.
Once again, sympathetic
system prepares
us for fight or flight,
and parasympathetic
mediates rest and
digest that is how
you can describe
most of their effects
functions that do not
fit these criteria
are effects of the ans
on external genitalia
but there is
another mnemonic to
remember parasympathetic
and sympathetic
actions for ******** and
ejaculation, and it
is point and shoot.
Please keep in mind
that certain organs
only receive
sympathetic innervation.
Here is a general overview
of the similarities
and differences
between sympathetic and
parasympathetic nervous
systems. They both
innervate internal
organs of the head, neck
and trunk as well as
external genitalia.
In addition,
sympathetic
nervous system also
innervates the
adrenal medulla,
sweat glands,
erector hair
muscle and all
vascular smooth
muscle. Therefore,
sympathetic system
is distributed to
all tissues, and
parasympathetic doesn't
reach limbs or
body wall, with the
exception of the
external genitalia.
Let's now briefly talk
about ANS embryology.
the peripheral part of
the autonomic nervous
system is derived
from the neural crest
in other words neural
crest cells differentiate
into all autonomic
ganglia adrenal
medulla and enteric
nervous system we'll talk
about this soon in
more detail but what I
would like you to pay
your attention to is
the adrenal medulla
where neural crest cells
differentiate into
neuroendocrine chromaffin
cells that release
epinephrine and nor
epinephrine let's
talk about neural tube
organization this
schematic shows development
of the neural tube
the dorsal sensory and
the ventral motor
house are separated by
this midline groove
called sulcus limitants.
Right above and
below the sulcus are
visceral sensory
and motor neurons.
In the spinal cord
somatic motor nuclei
make up the ventral
horn while this part
where the visceral
motor nuclei are becomes
intermedial lateral
cell column. In the
brace stem, the dorsal
part of the neural
tube opens up, so
motor nerves are medial
and the sensory
are lateral.
And here is the
sulcus limitance
that we talked
about earlier.
So here is an
anatomical overview
of the two opposing
branches of
the ANS. Sympathetic
on the left
and parasympathetic
on the right.
Both branches are
composed of two neurons,
presynaptic and
postsynaptic neurons.
Presynaptic
sympathetic neuron
bodies reside in
the thoracolumbar
segments of the
spinal cord, while
parasympathetic neurons
are in the brainstem,
so craniosacral
regions of the CNS.
Also this image
shows that both pre-
and post-synaptic
neurons of the
parasympathetic system
are cholinergic,
here shown in blue,
which means that
these neurons release
a settled cholin.
Sympathetic presynaptic
neurons are also
cholinergic, but
post-synaptic neurons
here shown in red
are noradrenergic,
meaning they release
the noradrenaline.
Now if we make
slices through
these regions and stain,
we can see intermedial
lateral column in
the thoracolumbar region
where the presynaptic
neurons of the
sympathetic nervous system
reside. And in the
brainstem, for example,
we can see dorsal
motor nucleosophagus,
and it resides
on the middle
aspect of the
sulcus limitants
that we talked
about earlier.
In the sacral regions,
this is how it
looks like. We also
find an intermedial
lateral column
where presynaptic
neurons of parasympathetic
system reside.
Let's talk more about
the cranial nerves
that carry
parasympathetic fibers.
These nuclei contain
the cell bodies of
the preganglionic
parasympathetic neurons
and are labeled
here with bold text.
Other cranial nerves
that are not involved
in controlling the
ANS are labeled gray.
So for For instance,
the Edinger-Westphal
nucleus is in
the midbrain and
contains cell
bodies of preganglionic
fibers that
travel with the
cranial nerve 3.
The superior salivatory
nucleus is on
the border of pons
and medulla and
contains cell bodies
of preganglionic
fibers that travel
with cranial nerve 7.
The inferior
cellulatory nucleus
is in the medulla
and contains cell
bodies of preganglionic
fibers that
travel with the
cranial nerve 9.
The nucleus ambiguous
is in the medulla
and the rostral
portion of this nucleus
contains preganglionic
cell bodies that
distribute with the
cranial nerve 9. The
rest of the nucleus
amigus and the
dorsal motor nucleus
of vagus are also in
medulla, containing
cell bodies of
preganglionic fibers
that travel with cranial
nerve 10, to host of
terminal ganglia in
the viscera of the
thorax and abdomen.
This schematic shows an
autonomic innervation
of the head and
neck target tissues.
And we can see where are
the cranial
nerve synapses.
So cranial nerve
3 is synapses in
ciliary ganglion,
and postganglionic
fibers innervate
pupillary
constrictor muscle
and ciliary muscle.
Cranial nerve 7
innervates lacrimal and
naisal mucosal glands
via pterygopalatin
ganglion, and also
inner with submandibular
and sublingual glands
through submandibular
ganglion. Cranial
nerve 9 innervates
parotid gland via otic
ganglion for here.
Sympathetic innervation
on the other
hand for the head
and neck tissue comes
from the thoracic
regions 1 and 2
via superior
cervical ganglion and
innervates pupillary
dilator muscle, sweat
glands, and vascular
smooth muscle.
Now if these
sympathetic nerves get
damaged anywhere along
this axis, patients
develop three signs
such as droopy
eyelid, constricted
pupil, and sometimes
loss of sweating
on the same side
of the face where
the damage happen.
Now let's talk
about similarities
and differences between
the parasympathetic
and sympathetic
innervation.
While somatic
lower motor neuron
directly
innervate skeletal
muscle shown
here at the top,
the autonomic
innervation is
composed of two
neurons that
synapse in the
peripheral ganglia.
The two opposing ANS
branches share many
other similarities such as
myelinated preganglionic
and myelinated
postganglionic neurons.
Preganglionic neurons
always release
acetylcholin, so they
are called cholinergic,
and they activate
nicotinic
receptors at the
postganglionic neurons. So
these synapses are
always excitatory.
Here we will go over
differences
between the two.
While sympathetic
preganglionic neurons reside
in the toracolumbar
sections of the spinal
cord, parasympathetic
preganglionic neurons
are found in the
cranial sacral regions.
Postganglionic neurons
are longer in the
sympathetic systems
and this is because
sympathetic ganglia
are found near the
spinal cord, while
parasympathetic ganglia
are near or within
the target tissues.
The exception of
this is adrenal
medulla, where
chromaffin neuroendocrine
cells act as
postganglionic neurons.
Postganglionic
parasympathetic neurons are
cholinergic, so they
release acetylcholine,
and sympathetic are
adrenergic and they
release noradrenaline
there are two exceptions
so sweat glands and
are innervated by
isetic choline although
they are part of the
sympathetic branch and
also adrenal medulla
releases norepinephrine
and epinephrine
epinephrine is has
an extra metal group
which extends its life
and this is how the
effects of sympathetic
system are prolonged.
Lastly, the effect
of sympathetic
and parasympathetic
innervation depend
on the receptors
and can be excitatory
and inhibitory
and this depends
on the receptor
expressed in the
target tissue.
Here is a list of
G protein coupled
receptors in the
ANS target tissues.
On the top are
muscarinic receptors that
mediate mainly
parasympathetic effects
and on the bottom
are adrenergic
receptors that mediate
sympathetic effects.
Depending on the G
protein these receptors
are coupled with they
can be excitatory
or inhibitory and once
again sweat glands
are an exception
here and they express
muscarinic receptors
although they are part
of the sympathetic
inherited by sympathetic
branch of the autonomic
nervous system
attention was
focused on these two
neurotransmitters
for a long time so
on acetylcholine
and noradrenaline,
primarily because
they mediate large
and fast post-synaptic
responses that can
be easily studied.
More recently, it has
become evident that
some neurotransmission
in the ANS involves
neither adrenergic nor
cholinergic pathways,
and moreover, many
neuronal synapses use more
than single
neurotransmitter in the ANS.
Such code
transmission is now
known to be
common in the ANS.
Here is a schematic of
sympathetic code
transmission.
ATP and noradrenaline
are released from
small granular vesicles
and act on P2X and
alpha-1 adrenoreceptors,
respectively,
that are found on
the smooth muscle,
that lead to an increase
in intracerebral
calcium concentration
and contraction.
Neuropeptide Y is stored
in large granule
vesicles,
and it acts as a
prejunctional inhibitory
modulator of ATP and
noradrenaline release,
and as a postjunctional
modulatory
potentiator of ATP and
noradrenaline actions.
Now, there is another
difference between
somatic and autonomic
nervous systems.
Somatic innervation
of the skeletal
striated muscles
happens at the defined
neuromuscular junctions,
as shown here.
In A is a diagram
showing a motor axon
that branches in to
innervate two muscle
fibers and their
neuromuscular junctions.
please notice extensive
branching of the
motor axon terminal
and this region where
this arrow shows where
the nerve has been
removed and it
reveals post-synaptic
folds in B is a human
neuromuscular junction
showing the nerve
terminal immunolabeled
with synaptophysin
in green and as post
-synaptic acetylcholine
receptors in red.
Notice the swollen buton
of the nerve terminal
from which the
transmitter is released.
C is an electron
micrograph of a
section through
a single buton.
Notice the extensive
infolding of the
postsynaptic muscular
muscle fiber membrane.
Smooth muscle
innervation, on the
other hand, does
not have such
defined neuromuscular
injunctions.
On the left is a
scanning electron
micrograph of a single
terminal varicose
nerve fiber lying
over the smooth
muscle of the rat's
small intestine.
Their connections are
called synapses
in passing.
Now if we zoom on one
of these varicosities
you would see this
image on the right
and this is an
electromycrograph of
autonomic varicosity in
guinea pig vast efforts
and it shows dense
prejunction of
thickening and bunching
of vesicles which
probably represent
transmitter release sites
as pointed by these
arrows However, there
is no post-junctional
specialization.
In summary,
striated muscles
have a motor end
plate, a specialized
area where
somatic neurons
synapse and where there
is a high density
of receptors.
Also the striated muscles
can only be excited.
Smooth muscles,
on the other hand,
don't have specialized
synapses, but
rather synapses in
passing and can be
excited or inhibited
depending on the
receptors expressed
on the muscle fibers
summary image once
again i will emphasize
once more the two oddities
of the sympathetic
division first
while most of the
postganglionic neurons
are adrenergic sweat
glands are innervated by
cholinergic postsynaptic
neurons that release
acetylcholine
and act on the muscarinic
m3 receptors to
stimulate sweating the
other one is adrenal
medulla where chromaffin
cells serve as
postganglionic nerves
and release adrenaline
and noradrenaline
into the bloodstream
now while parasympathetic
neuron synapse
in the ganglia close
to the target organs
sympathetic division
has two sets of
ganglia, paravertebral
and prevertebral.
So preganglionic
nerves have
a few potential pathways.
Let's look at this
closer and if we zoom
on to one of these
regions over here, we
can see that the
cell body of each
preganglionic neuron
lies in the intromidio
lateral cord over here
of the spinal cord.
Its fiber passes
through the ventral horn
of the cord into the
corresponding spinal
nerve and immediately
after the spinal nerve
leaves the spinal
canal the preganglionic
sympathetic fibers
leave the spinal nerve
and pass through the
white ramus into one
of the ganglia of the
sympathetic chain.
The fibers then
can take one
of the following
three courses.
They can synapse with
the post ganglionic
neuron in the ganglion
that they enter.
Number two, they
can pass upward or
downward of the chain
and synapse in one
of the other ganglia
of the chain. Or
three, they can pass
for variable of distance
through the chain
and then through
one of the sympathetic
nerves radiating
outward from the chain
finally synapsing
in the peripheral
sympathetic ganglion.
The postganglionic
sympathetic neuron
therefore originates
either in one of
the sympathetic
chain ganglia or in
one of the peripheral
sympathetic
ganglia. The
postganglionic fibers then
leave to their
destinations in various
Now that we are
familiar with the
general concepts,
let's talk about
several atomic nervous
system reflexes.
You saw the simplified
schematic on how
the baroreceptor
reflex keeps the blood
pressure within a
narrow range. And now
let's talk more in
detail. So high blood
pressure stretches
the arterial wall
and increases
baroreceptor firing rate.
This excitatory signal
is relayed via cranial
nerve 9 and 10
afferents to the nucleus
tractus solitarius
where they excite the
second order neurons
that project into nucleus
ambiguous and caudal
ventral lateral
medulla and a over here
houses parasympathetic
neurons that get
excited and reduce the
heart rate on the
other hand CVLM is the
inhibitory center and
it activation Inhibition
inhibits the neurons
in the rostral ventral
lateral medulla and
in the A1 over here.
This decreased activity
of the RVLM and A1
centers results in reduced
sympathetic activity
and reduction of the
ADH or vasopressin
release from the
parvoventricular nucleus or
PVN over here and the
supraoptic nucleus over
here of the hypothalamus.
This further
reduces the heart rate
and causes vasodilatation,
which further reduces
the blood pressure.
On the other hand,
low blood pressure
decreases the firing rate
of the baroreceptors,
which reduces the
parasympathetic activity
via NTS and NA and
increases the sympathetic
activity through
reduced activity of the
inhibitory CVLM and
therefore increases the
activity of the baroreceptors.
the RVLM and A1.
The latter two
cause an increase in
the heart rate and
vasoconstriction,
increasing the
blood pressure.
To make this
schematic more
complete, we will
briefly mention the
role of glial
cells in the NTS.
This schematic
illustrates the
proposed mechanisms
involved with
the modulation of
the baroreflex.
If we zoom on the vagal
afferents ending
in the NNN,
we can see that
vagal afferents
terminals release
serotonin and glutamate
acting on the
second-order relayed
neurons and astrocytes
in the NTS. In
response to incoming
afferent inflammation,
these NTS astrocytes
release ATP,
which restricts
the expression of
baroreflex via
activation of the P2Y1
receptors on the
NTS inhibitory
interneurons. And
this is how astrocytes
modulate the
baroreflex sensitivity.
Now let's see a nice
summary animation
that summarizes the
baroreceptor reflex.
Increased blood
pressure stretches the
carotid arteries and
aorta, causing the
baroreceptors to
increase their basal
rate of action
potential generation.
Action potentials
are conducted by the
glossopharyngeal and
vagus nerves to the
cardioregulatory and
vasomotor centers in
the medulla oblongata.
As a result of increased
stimulation from the
baroreceptors, the
cardioregulatory center
increases parasympathetic
stimulation to
the heart, which
decreases the heart rate.
Also, as a result
of the increased
stimulation from the
baroreceptors, the
cardiovascular center
decreases sympathetic
stimulation to
the heart, which
decreases heart rate
and ****** volume.
The vasomotor center
decreases sympathetic
stimulation to
blood vessels,
causing vasodilation.
The vasodilation,
along with the
decreased heart rate and
decreased ****** volume
bring the elevated
blood pressure
back toward normal.
If the initial problem
were a decrease
in blood pressure,
the activities and
effects of the
baroreceptors, cardiovascular
center, and vasomotor
center would
be the opposite of
what is illustrated.
Now let's talk about
several phenomena
that involve the
baroreceptor reflex, and
one of them is
orthostatic hypertension.
The stress of
standing up from the
supine position
results in a shift
of blood from
the chest to the
stretchable venous
system of the legs.
This venous pooling
rapidly reduces central
blood volume and
this reduction is
compounded by increased
capillary filtration
of plasma through the
increased hydrostatic
pressure in this
venous system. The
reduction in the central
blood volume decreases
cardiac filling and
****** volume or the
volume that is pumped
by each heartbeat.
Now in health
individuals heart rate
increases on standing
but not enough to
compensate for the
reduction in the ******
volume so cardiac
output decreases.
The key regulatory
adjustment to the upright
posture are arterial
baroreflex-mediated
constriction of arterioles
and splenchy venous
capacitors vessels, with
a subsequent increase
in systemic vascular
resistance that
compensates for the
decrease in the cardiac
outcome and therefore
maintains normal tension.
In healthy
individuals, mean blood
pressure changes
a little, as
shown in this
graph on the right.
Systolic blood
pressure decreases only
slightly, if at all, and
diastolic blood pressure
increases now if this
regulation doesn't
happen in some people
they have prolonged
decrease in the systemic
blood pressure as
you can see on the
graph over here and
this we call classic
orthostatic hypotension
There are several
physical counter
maneuvers to increase
blood pressure in
patients with
orthostatic hypotension.
So you can see
over here the red
lines show the effect
of crossing the
legs, placing the
foot on a chair,
squatting when
standing and crossing
the legs while
seated. The arrows
indicate the duration
of the maneuvers
and notice please
the increase in
blood pressure and
pulse pressure.
Another maneuver
that relies on the
baroreceptor reflex
is carotid sinus
massage as shown
here on this image.
Physical pressure
of the sinus is
perceived as an increase
in blood pressure,
so it increases firing
from the body receptors
and outcome is the
reduced heart rate.
This can serve as
an initial treatment
of paroxysmal
supraventricular tachycardia
and for the evaluation
of syncope in
patients older than
40 years of age.
However, there are some
serious contraindications
to using this
procedure, such as
patients who are at
risk or already had
transitory ischemic
attack or ******.
So, while doing this
carotid massage,
we can affect and
reduce the heart
rate. Another
condition in which
baroreceptor reflex
actually causing
problems is autonomic
dysreflexia.
This condition
typically happens in the
spinal cord injury
above T6 segment.
And it causes
hypersensitivity of the
autonomic reflexes to
sensory stimuli. So in this
nice schematic, in
this nice diagram, we
can see that sensory
stimuli such as impacted
****** or distended
urinary bladder cause
synthetic surge,
which in turn causes
massive widespread
plaza constriction that
leads to peripheral
arterial hypertension. And
this of course is
detected by baroreceptors
in the neck which lead
to parasympathetic
slowing of the heart
called bradycardia.
So this can lead
to uncontrolled
hypertension
in bradycardia
and can be life
threatening.
Now we switch gears
and talk about the
innervation of the
urinary bladder.
This schematic
shows efferent
pathways of the
lower urinary tract.
Sympathetic fibers,
shown here in blue,
originate in the T11
to L2 segments of
the spinal cord
and run through the
inferior mesenteric
ganglia and
hypogastric nerve or
through the paralytribal
chain to enter the
pelvic nerves at
the base of the
bladder and urethra.
Parasympathetic
ganglionic fibers, here
shown in green,
arise from the S2
and to S4 spinal
segments and travel in
the sacral roots
and pelvic nerves to
the ganglia and
pelvic plexus, and
going all the way
to the bladder wall.
And this is where
postganglionic
nerves that supply
parasympathetic
innervation to
the bladder arise.
Somatic motor nerves,
here shown in yellow,
supply the striated
muscle of the
external urethral
sphincter and they arise
from S2 to S4
motor neuron levels
and pass through
the pudendal nerves.
Here on the right
we can see efferent
pathways what we
just talked about
and neurotransmitter
mechanisms that
regulate the lower
urinary tract.
Parasympathetic
postganglionic
fibers, again showing
green over here,
release acetylcholine,
which produces
a bladder contraction by
stimulating M3
oscarinic receptors in
the smooth muscle
of the bladder.
Sympathetic postganglionic
neurons, here
in blue, release
noradrenaline, which
activates beta-3
adrenergic receptors
to relax bladder
smooth muscle, and
also activates alpha
-1 adrenergic receptors
to contract urethral
smooth muscle.
Somatic axons here
in yellow in the
pudendal nerve also
release acetylcholine,
which produces contraction
of the external
sphincter
striated muscle by
activating nicotinic
cholinergic receptors.
Now, when we
learned about neural
circuits that control
continence and
migration, we can
start talking about
reflexes that control
urine storage.
During the storage of
urine, the extension
of the bladder
produces low-level
visceral afferent
firing. and this in turn
stimulates sympathetic
outflow in the
hypogastric nerve to
the bladder outlet so
that it causes
constriction of the urethra
and also activates
pudendal nerve as an
outflow to the external
urethral sphincter
so this sphincter
gets contracted too.
These responses occur
by spinal reflex
pathways and
represent guardian
reflexes which promote
continence. Sympathetic
firing also
inhibits contraction
of the trusor
muscle and modulates
neuron transmission
in bladder ganglia.
A region in the
rostral pons, the
pontine storage
center, might increase
striated urethral
sphincter activity.
Now let's talk about
voiding reflexes.
During the elimination
of urine, intense
bladder afferent
filling in the
pelvic nerve activates
spinal-bulbospinal
reflex pathways,
here shown in blue,
and they pass through the
pontine
necturation center.
This in turn stimulates
the parasympathetic
outflow of the bladder
and to the urethral
smooth muscle here
shown in green and also
inhibits the sympathetic
and pudendal outflow
to the urethral outlet
here shown in red.
A setting afferent
input from the spinal
cord might pass through
relay neurons in the
periaqueductal gray
before reaching the
pontine mixturation
center as shown over here.
Now let's talk
about bladder
dysregulation in the
spinal cord injury.
Injuries between the
mid thoracic spinal
cord and the pontine
mixturation center
here shown by these
red scissors usually
cause ******* bladder
or upper motor
neuron bladder in
which vesicle vesicle
reflex re-emerges and
becomes hyperactive.
External sphincter
never gets a signal
from the pontine
maturation center telling
it to relax so all
stay contracted.
The trusor has to
contract really really
hard to produce enough
pressure to overcome
the contracted sphincter
so urine can back
up into the ureters
and to the kidneys.
On the other hand,
atonic bladder or
lower motor neuron
bladder happens in
lesions of the conus
medullaris cauda equina
or sacral cord as
shown by the red
scissors over here
again in which the
trusor is unable to
contract so bladder
expands under
relatively low pressure.
This bladder
fills up but never
completely empties.
So external sphincters
are not contracted
and small
amount of urine may
slowly leak out.
In the last part of
this session we're
going to talk about
enteric nervous system.
So intestines house
as many neurons as
found in the spinal
cord. In this picture
is a whole mound of
mouse embryonic intestine
showing enteric
neuronal cell bodies
in blue and innervation
in red and green.
Enteric nervous system
is organized into
two networks that
spread along the whole
digestive tract. So
in red we have my
enteric plexus that
is sandwiched between
two muscle layers
and mostly controls
gut motility and
submucosal plexus find
submucosally or
below mucosa which
controls the epithelial
functions mostly.
Enteric neural
system contains
complete circuits
for the reflex
control of the
digestive tract.
Therefore, a
segment of intestine
can perform basic
functions when
it is removed
from an animal.
On the left is a sped
up video of the colon
motility in the organ
bath. So you can see
that colonic motility
is still happening
in the complete absence
of the innervation.
How does this coordinated
movement happen?
This reflex is encoded
by the enteric nervous
system, mostly my
enteric plexus that is
sandwiched between
the two muscle layers.
And you can also
see that in addition
to neurons, we also
have glia cells, which
are necessary for
neuronal survival.
Let's first talk about
the gut motility reflex.
Gut distension or
chemical stimuli by the
luminal contact excite
intrinsic sensory
neurons, here shown in
yellow. And these sensory
neurons activate local
excitatory co-energic
motor neurons and
ascending interneurons,
ascending interneuron
synapse onto more
proximal excitatory
motor neurons, but also
on the descending
interneurons that activate
inhibitory nitrologic
motor neurons. This
synaptic convergence of
ascending and descending
interneurons means
that increased
activation of ascending
pathways leads to a
corresponding increased
activation of descending
inhibitory pathways
and allows coordination
of neural activity
over large distances.
And thus we always see
contraction above the
stimuli and relaxation
below the stimuli.
Gut epithelial
secretions are
controlled by the
monosynaptic reflex.
In response to chemical
stimuli from the
lumen, gut epithelial
cells activate
primary sensory
afferents that, in turn,
stimulate secretromotor
neurons to
release vasoactive
intestinal peptide and
acetylcholine back
onto the epithelium.
Epithelial cells respond
by increase in cyclic
AMP and activation
of chloride channels.
The active release
of chloride
ions is followed
by passive
diffusion of
sodium and water.
So this is how
secretaromotor function is
controlled by the
enteric nervous system.
Lastly, we will learn
about Hirschbrand's
disease. This disease
happens because neural
crest cells fail to
migrate all the way to the
****, and since neural
crest cells give rise
to the enteric
nervous system, these
pediatric patients do not
have enteric ganglia in
a segment of the ******
and distal column,
and therefore dead
part of the digestive
tube cannot
generate peristaltic
contractions. As a
result, these new
bones suffer from
severe constipation.
On the right is
radiograph showing
aganglionic shrunken
part and enlarged
column above the
aganglionic region.
This is why this
disorder is also known
as congenital
aganglionic megacolumn.
As a summary slide,
I list here items
that you should
be familiar with.
so in this
lecture we talked
about the anatomic
nervous system
and how it regulates
homeostasis
we talked about two
of the three branches
which are parasympathetic
and sympathetic
and the main effects
of rest and digest
versus fight or flight
Now, be familiar
and understand the
connections of the ANS
centers in the brainstem
and hypothalamus,
similarities and
differences between the
sympathetic and
parasympathetic divisions,
actions of the mascarinic
and adrenergic receptors,
then somatic
versus autonomic
muscle innervation,
baroreceptor
reflex, orthostatic
hypotension,
carotid sinus massage,
and autonomic
dysreflexia,
and also innervation
and reflexes of the
urinary system, as well
as disorders such as
******* and atonic
bladder. Lastly, be
familiar with the enteric
nervous system networks
such as myenteric
or Auerbach's and
submucosal or Meissner's
networks or plexuses.
Know the gut motility
and secretomotor
reflexes and lastly the
Hischsprung's disease.
with that I encourage
you to use the link
here provide feedback
this session on the
neuroanatomy and
physiology of the autonomic
nervous system as well
as some disorders that
happen with the dysfunction
of the autonomic
innervation I hope
you enjoy this lecture
and thank you for
listening in your attention